Film Courage: Have you had a moment in your
life where you say “I’m going to make
movies for the rest of my life?”
Or you’ve never really had to have this
moment where there is light beaming down on
you and…you know what I’m saying?
Has it just been where you’ve gone from
one film to the next or has there been someone
where this voice has come to you and said
“I’ve got to do this for the rest of my
life.
You’ve were meant to do this.”
Matthew Berkowitz, Filmmaker: No it’s every
day.
I wake up every day and I have the voice telling
me “You have to do this for the rest of
your life.”
Every day I wake up and every night I go to
sleep thinking that same thing.
Film Courage: Is that your voice?
Matthew: Yes.
Film Courage: Is that because you’ve had
other jobs?
Well you’re like “This is what I do.
I want to love what I do even if it gets hard.
And there is difficult people involved.”
Matthew: Yes, I’ve done other jobs.
I’ve had a lot of jobs.
I’ve done a lot of jobs in film.
I think I’ve pretty much worked every position
on a film set you can.
But there is something about being in love
with your craft that you can never take away
from yourself, that you can never deny.
So there is a tremendous amount of uncertainty
being a filmmaker.
My mentor (Robert A. Ferretti) he’s made every
film since TANGO AND CASH to DIE HARD to ROCKY.
You know I’ll call him and be terrified
and I’ll say “Bobby, I’m on the edge
of my seat.
I don’t know what I’m doing with my life?
I just want to make movies.”
And he says “Get with it dude!
I live with the same thing every day.”
Right?
Which is you don’t know when your next movie
is going to come.
You don’t know if you’re going to be wildly
successful.
You don’t know if your movie is going to
be good.
You kind of make each film like it might be
your last one because you’ve got to love
it like that.
I don’t I think that in any point of your
career you are faced with that reality and
those challenges which is you just don’t
do it because it’s the only thing that is
there.
It’s the only thing you want to do.
It’s the only thing you can do.
That’s why I make movies.
I think that is what great filmmakers make
movies is because they don’t really have
another choice.
Film Courage: So how was that to hear it from
someone that has so many great titles under
their belt so to speak that they live with
that same anxiety?
Matthew: It’s refreshing, it’s good.
It makes me understand a little bit more.
It’s kind of the world that has evolved.
It’s like having your own social contract
with yourself.
You’ve signed the contract saying “I’m
going to live the life of being a filmmaker”
where you are trying your hardest to make
movies every day and there are no guarantees.
Film Courage: Do you think that’s what makes
it so enticing aside from the creative aspect
and seeing this “thing” come together,
the fact that it’s not that guaranteed?
And then when it does work…
Matthew: It’s magic?
Yes, I think that is what’s so enticing
about it.
There’s a lot of moments of magic in making
a film.
There’s the moment of magic when you’re
writing your script and you’ve stared at
the screen for 10 hours and you can’t figure
out what you want this character to say.
You’ve been typing words for hours and hours
and hours and typing in circles and finally
you crack it with just one line of dialogue
and then you’re off.
And it’s the same moment where you’re
working and working and working and then you’re
get a little bit of money and then you’re
off making your movie.
And then there’s that moment where you step
on set and you set up your lights and you’re
blocking the scene with your actors and you
see that scene the way you want to shoot it
and it just flows and you just capture this
perfect scene and you could have never shot
listed it, you could have never planned it,
it just happened.
And that’s cinema, that’s making movies.